スティーブ:こんにちは
こちらスティーブです
スティーブ:今日はねもう日本語で話
するわけですよで特別なゲストがあります
スティーブ:Kazu Languagesのカズさん
カズ:こんにちは
スティーブ:こんにちは
僕のビデオを好きであれば
スティーブ:是非チャンネル登録
してください
スティーブ:今日はですね日本語で
僕カズをインタビューしたい
スティーブ:なぜかと言うとカズさんが
いろんな言葉ができるわけですよ
スティーブ:僕は日本に
9年間も住んでて
スティーブ:その丸善ブックスストアとか
どこ行ってもですね英語しかない
スティーブ:勉強する外国語っていうのは英語
半分以上は英語
スティーブ:で少し中国語とスペイン語
韓国語そんなもんですよね
スティーブ:それで
そしてよく言われるのは
スティーブ:もう日本人がもう英語しか
興味無いと
スティーブ:しかしカズさん
ちょっと自己紹介的に
スティーブ:その自分のチャンネルは
どういう内容なものと
スティーブ:そしてカズさんは
どんな言葉を勉強したかと
スティーブ:ちょっと紹介
私のオーディエンスに紹介してください
カズ:僕がその言語を学習する
目的っていうのは
カズ:やっぱりその人と関わることが
1番僕は興味があって
カズ:なのでその言語ってすごい
すごい力があると思っていて
カズ:なのでその人と関わる中で
その人のリアクションとか
カズ:あとその言語を学ぶことで
カズ:その文化へのリスペクトに
繋がってると思っているので
カズ:このチャンネルでは
色んな人と色んな世界中の国の人と
カズ:その人の母国語で話す
っていうことをやっていて
カズ:で今えーと話す言語は日本語 英語
スペイン語 フランス語 ポルトガル語
カズ:インドネシア語 ロシア語
アラビア語を勉強しています
スティーブ:面白いのはね
そのあれですよ
スティーブ:ロマンス系のね
例えばフランス語 イタリア語 ポルトガル語
スティーブ:それだけだとね
言えばやり易い
スティーブ:しかしカズさんの場合は
インドネシア語 アラビア語 スラヴ系の言葉
スティーブ:それからヨーロッパの言葉
なんか幅広い興味ですね
スティーブ:どういう風にそのどの言葉を勉強するか
どういう風に選びますか？
カズ:そうですね あの僕が
その新しい言語を勉強する時に
カズ:特に大事にしてるのが
カズ:凄く逆に全然違う言語を
学びたいっていうのが
カズ:思っていて
カズ:例えばその文化っていう
観点でもそうですし
カズ:そうですね生活だとか
その日本と全然違う
カズ:国の言語を学びたくて
カズ:なのであえてその
ランゲージファミリーが違う言語を
カズ:あの色んな世界中の国を
できるだけ学びたいなと思って
カズ:幅広く選択しています
スティーブ:ヨーロッパ行きますとね
スティーブ:よくこう…
スティーブ:モンドリンゴを
リンゴモンドっていうか
スティーブ:そのどっかの
パブでねいろんな人が集まって
スティーブ:そしてみんなそのできる
言葉言語をですね 旗が胸に張ってですね
スティーブ:そして回ったりですね
スティーブ:そしてみんなお互いに
色んな言葉で話するわけですよ
スティーブ:でもちろんヨーロッパは
もう隣の国がもう言葉が違うわけですから
スティーブ:いろんな言葉の
できる人が結構いる訳ですよね
スティーブ:日本の場合はどうなんですか？
スティーブ:こういうその
いわゆるポリグロフに対する
スティーブ:そういういろんな
言葉を言語を勉強したいというか
スティーブ:そういう動きっていうか
あるんですか？
カズ:そうですねまだ日本では
あんまり普及はしてはいないんですけど
カズ:やっぱり特に最近英語への
熱がすごい高まってて
カズ:昔は全然もう日本人全然日本語
話せないっていう風に言われてたんですけど
カズ:最近は結構変わってきてて
カズ:英語を真剣に
学ぶ人も増えてきていますし
カズ:例えば大学とかで
第2外国語っていう感じで
カズ:なんかスペイン語とか中国語とか
結構色んな言語が選択できるので
カズ:そこで選択する人もいますし
カズ:やっぱりちょっと言語に対する
姿勢がみんな変わってきてるのかなっていうのは
カズ:感じています
スティーブ:英語だとかねあるいは
スペイン語 ロシア語ですね
スティーブ:そのいわゆる
コンペアリング インプットですね
スティーブ:コンテンツが
色んな面白い内容のものがね
スティーブ:ポッドキャストだとか
スティーブ:テレビ番組とか
いろんなものがあるんですけれども
スティーブ:僕はねアラビア語の場合は
ちょっと苦労してるわけですよ
スティーブ:苦戦してますよ
スティーブ:適切なそのオーディオ
そしてそれにいわゆるテキストもついててですね
スティーブ:しかし僕のレベルでと
スティーブ:なかなか探しにくいですよね
スティーブ:でインドネシア語
僕も全然知りませんけれども
スティーブ:どうでしょう
インドネシア語 アラビア語でその
スティーブ:カズさんに合うような
スティーブ:いわゆる興味のある
レベルも合うような
スティーブ:勉強内容その勉強の
その材料を探すのはどうなんですか？
スティーブ:難しいですか？
カズ:そうですね かなり難しいですね 特にその…
カズ:アラビア語の
エジプト方言が凄く難しくて
カズ:全然 全然インターネットにもなくて
カズ:なので…
カズ:やっぱり基本的にはYouTubeと
Netflixを見ることが多いですね
スティーブ:確かにYouTubeが非常に
良い源ですよ YouTubeというのは
カズ:はい 本当にそうですね
YouTube
スティーブ:そのレバノンの物も結構あるでしょ
カズ:あぁレバノン はい
スティーブ:アラビア語でちょっと
コンフューズしてましてね
スティーブ:時々レバノンのものを
聞いたりエジプトの物を聞いたり
スティーブ:スタンダードアラビア語を聴いたり なかなか難しい
カズ:いろいろありますもんね
スティーブ:そうですね
スティーブ:あの今日本に住んでて
住んでいらっしゃいますか？
カズ:あーもうあの
ほぼずっと日本に住んでます
スティーブ:今からどこか
外国へ行く計画ございますか？
カズ:そうですね今やっぱり
言語学習に集中したいんですけど
カズ:そう来年か再来年あたりで
カズ:その自分が勉強した
言語が話されている国を
カズ:旅行したいなって思ってます
スティーブ:なるほど
スティーブ:そういう旅行というのは
やはりえー言葉を勉強してね
スティーブ:こうして一生懸命
勉強した後
スティーブ:国へ行くとですね
スティーブ:夢みたいな…夢みたいですよ
カズ:そう 特別な
スティーブ:本当に使える
スティーブ:本当に実際の
毎日のその生活に
スティーブ:その一生懸命勉強した
言葉を使えるっていうのは
スティーブ:大変なその楽しみですよ
カズ:そうですね
スティーブ:具体的にどこの国
南米とかヨーロッパとかロシア
スティーブ:あるいはエジプトどこ
インドネシア1番近いでしょ
カズ:そう そうですね
カズ:まずインドネシアたくさん
友達がいるのでインドネシアも行きたいですし
カズ:特に南米はポルトガル語も
スペイン語もどっちも勉強したので
カズ:あのそこを回りたいっていうのも
ありますし世界中行きたいです
スティーブ:なかなか良いですね
スティーブ:僕はそのやはり
スティーブ:誰でも1つの外国語
だけじゃなくて
スティーブ:いくつかの外国語を
勉強できるはずなんですよ
スティーブ:そして今インターネットとか
MP3とかね
スティーブ:いろんな技術があるから
前よりずっと勉強しやすくなったわけですから
スティーブ:そして非常に1人の人生も
それだけには豊かになりますから
スティーブ:本当にカズさんのように
我々同じアレですよ言葉をあれですよ
スティーブ:発見する 発見家ですよね
カズ:発見する はい
カズ:恐縮です
スティーブ:OK それで
スティーブ:いずれカズさんの
YouTubeのリンクね
スティーブ:ディスクリプションボックス
の所へ残します
[スペイン語で会話］
スティーブ:あの分かりましたのは
スティーブ:バハサ・インドネシアだけ
だけだけ！
スティーブ:しかし将来
場合によってはこのインドネシア語を勉強する
スティーブ:OK! どうもありがとう
スティーブ:色々楽しかったです
スティーブ:頑張ってください
カズ:ありがとうございます
スティーブ:僕よりずっと若いですから
スティーブ:これからさらに
10も20ヶ国語勉強してください
カズ:はい頑張ります Thank you so much.
スティーブ:Thank you, Bye bye.